hello everybody it's great to see my
gosh so many friends actually and indeed
my husband which is alarming he never
turns up to any event I do but
um it is great to be here uh to talk
with about literally one of the hottest
topics of the moment with someone who
has written one of the best books about
it
um how many of you have used chat GPT
just a show of hands
virtually everybody
I think you'd probably then agree that
chat DBT what came November last year
and it was only then that most people
realized that artificial intelligence
generative AI models in particular were
about to change the world and suddenly
there was a kind of collective Global oh
my God this capability is extraordinary
and it's been reflected in endless
numbers of editorials handwringing
politicians and I think I'm right and
saying the main focus has been on the
downsides everyone has their pet view of
what the odds are of existential risk
are we all going to kill ourselves it's
all terrible
and Mustafa comes into this as a man
with considerable credibility he is a
man who has co-founded not just one but
two successful AI companies
and she's a man who in this book takes a
sober
realistic and actually very compelling
look at what lies ahead of us and so
that's why you really should read it
it's great I've read it twice uh you
should read it Mustafa just to give you
some he doesn't need much introduction I
don't think to this group but he was a
co-founder of deepmind back in 2010. uh
he then was a co-founder of inflection
AI with Reed Hoffman Reed Hoffman his
co-founder has with the help of chat GPT
written an extremely upbeat view of the
potential of this technology so I'd love
to know the debates between the two of
you
um he was got a CBE a few years ago for
his Visionary services and influence in
the UK technology sector
um he is also on the board of The
Economist so I get to see Mustafa
working up close
um uh he's a friend of The Economist
friend of uh and great figure in British
technology
but I think
and the place to start with this book
and the book is called the coming wave
and you will know that there has been if
you've turned on your TV or listened to
a podcast recently you will know that
never mind the coming wave there is
already a wave of um publicity and
people being impressed with this book I
believe you've heard you told me 60
appearances of various sorts so consider
yourselves lucky you're 61 on this list
but understandably the work the book has
had a tremendous impact because it is
very interesting very thoughtful and
it's on the hottest Topic at the moment
so we want to talk most of the time
about the book but I do want to for
those of you who don't know Mustafa to
get a little bit of background and the
first is that Mustafa is actually not a
computer geek
you didn't study computer code right you
studied philosophy and theology at
Oxford so can you just give us the kind
of potted history about how a man who
studied philosophy and theology comes to
be the co-founder of two tech companies
what are you doing
well I've always found philosophy as
systems thinking tool it enables me to
be rigorous and clear about what I think
and you know right from the very outset
I think when I was 19 I actually dropped
out of My Philosophy degree I didn't
know that yeah I didn't finish and I was
really motivated by the impact that I
could have in the world I left to help
start a charity at the time it was a
telephone counseling service called
Muslim youth helpline and it was a
secular that I was a an atheist even
though I had grown up with a Muslim
background it was a secular service that
was designed to provide faith and
culturally sensitive support to Young
British Muslims this was in 2 2003
and you know I I found myself at Oxford
studying this very theoretical esoteric
you know set of ideas and I wanted to
put real things into practice in terms
of my ethics and that was why I went to
you know start the helpline and worked
on that as a volunteer for three years
uh I soon got you know frustrated about
the scale of impact
um in our non-profit and I worked
briefly for the mayor of London at the
time Ken Livingston
um as a human rights policy officer
um and you know that was that was
inspiring but I was also struggling with
the scale of impact I I realized that
you know if if I didn't capture what
really makes us organized and effective
as a species The Profit incentive then I
was going to miss one of the most
important things to happen in my
lifetime and
um at the time I saw the rise of
Facebook this was sort of around 2007
2008 and it had grown in the space of
two years to 100 million monthly active
users is and I was totally blown away at
how quickly this was growing out of
seemingly nowhere something completely
new to me and so I set about on a quest
to find anyone and everyone that would
speak to me to teach me about technology
I had started a bunch of businesses
before that two different businesses one
actually a technology company selling
electronic point of sale systems
actually around here in Notting Hill uh
in restaurants uh trying to put Wi-Fi
infrastructure in there and so on that
was a that was unsuccessful that was
ahead of its time and so I was looking
for people who I could you know form a
new partnership with and figure out how
to take advantage of of technology and
that's where I met my friend and
co-founder of deepmind Mrs arbis because
he was the brother of my best friend at
the time from school and he was just
finishing his PhD in neuroscience at UCL
and we got together and you know the
rest is history and at that time
you had
Patrol intelligence that was you know
capable of replicating human
intelligence or even succeeding it so
just think this was 13 years ago the
rest of us didn't even know this stuff
was really going on you're you're in
your where is it in Regent Square
somewhere
did you imagine that by 2023 the world
would have what we have now
I mean in a way yes it was difficult for
us to imagine exactly how it would
unfold but we made a very big bet on
deep learning uh which is one of the
primary tools that is powering this new
Revolution
um before anybody was involved in deep
learning so the the current chief
scientists and co-founder of openai the
creators of chat gbt was one of our
interns back in 2011. Jeffrey Hinton who
was the who subsequently became the um
one of the heads of AI at Google and is
known now as the Godfather of AI
recently in the Press worried about the
consequences
he was our first advisor our paid
advisor I think his salary was 25 000
pounds a year to advise us so I think
three of the six co-founders of openai
at some point passed through deepmind
either to give talks or were actually
members of the team so really it was
incredibly about timing you know we got
the timing absolutely right we were way
ahead of the curve at that moment and
somehow we managed to hang on so you you
were there for a while and then let's
fast forward a bit you can read the rest
of this in the book you you now have
co-founded and run inflection Ai and you
are creating an AI called Pi which you
can interact with if you like tell us
what pi does
so Pi stands for personal intelligence
and I believe that over the next few
years everybody is going to have their
own personal AI
there are going to be hundreds of
thousands of AIS in the world they'll
represent businesses they'll represent
Brands every government will have its
own AI every non-profit every musician
artist record label everything that is
now represented by a website or an app
is soon going to be represented by an
interactive conversational intelligent
service that represents the brand values
and the ideas of whatever organization
is out there and we believe that at the
same time everybody will want their own
personal AI one that is on your side in
your corner helping you to be more
organized helping you to make sense of
the world
it really is going to function as almost
like a chief of staff or you know
prioritizing planning teaching
supporting
supporting you so that sounds great
um what does it actually mean though in
practice because so often this
conversation about AI it's at this point
then it turns into the apocalyptic we're
going to end up you know wiping
ourselves out because there'll be some
Rogue person you know sitting in a
garage somewhere who will you know
unleash a virus that will kill us all so
before we get to all of that stuff
in let's say
I don't know five years and you said
within the next three to five years you
think AI will reach human level
capability across a variety of tasks
perhaps not everything but a variety so
paint a picture for us
of what life will be like in five years
at 2028 and first of all will it be you
and me here or will there be the kind of
Mustafa AI bot
okay let me let me just go back 10 years
just to to give you a sense for what has
already happened and why the predictions
they'll make I think are plausible so
the Deep learning Revolution enabled us
to make sense of raw messy data so we
could use AIS to interpret the content
of images classify whether an image
contains dogs or cats what those pixels
actually mean we can use it to
understand speech so when you dictate
into your phone and it transcribes it
and Records perfect text we can use it
to do language translation
all of these are classification tasks
we're essentially teaching the models to
understand the messy complicated world
of raw input data well enough to
understand the objects inside that data
that was the classification Revolution
the first 10 years now we're in the
generative Revolution right so these
models are now producing new images that
you've never seen before they're
producing new text that you've never
seen before they can generate pieces of
music and that's because it's the flip
side of that coin the first stage is
understanding and classifying if you
like the second stage having done that
well enough you can then ask the AI to
say given that you understand you know
what a dog looks like now generate me a
dog with your idea of pink with your
idea of yellow spots or whatever and
that is an inter
it's a prediction of the space between
two or three or four Concepts and that's
what's produced this generative AI
revolution in all of the modalities
as we apply more computation to this
process so we're basically stacking much
much larger AI models and we're stacking
much much larger data the accuracy and
the quality of these generative AIS gets
much much better so just to give you a
sense of the trajectory we're on with
respect to computation
over the last 10 years
every single year the amount of compute
that we have used for The Cutting Edge
AI models has grown by 10x so 10x 10x
10x 10x 10 times in a row now that is
unprecedented in technology history
nowhere else have we seen a trajectory
anything like that over the next five
years We'll add probably three or four
orders of magnitude basically another
thousand times the compute that you see
used today to produce gbt4 or the chat
model that you might interact with and
it's really important to understand that
that might be a technical detail or
something but it's important to grab
like sort of grasp that because when
people talk about gpt3 or gbt 3.5 or
gbt4
the distance between those models is in
fact 10 times compute it's not
incremental it's exponential and so the
difference between gbt4 and gbt2 is in
fact a hundred times worth of compute
the largest compute infrastructures in
the world basically to learn all the
relationships between all the inputs of
all of this raw data
what does that mean what does that
entail enable them to do in the next
phase we'll go from being able to
perfectly generate so
speech will be perfect video generation
will be perfect image generation will be
perfect language generation will be
perfect to now being able to plan across
multiple time Horizons so at the moment
you could only say to a model give me
you know a poem in the style of X give
me a new image that matches these two
Styles it's a sort of One-Shot
prediction next you'll be able to say
generate me a new product right in order
to do that you would need to have that
ai go off and do research to you know
look at the market and see what was
potentially going to sell what are
people talking about at the moment it
would then need to generate a new image
of what that product might look like
compared to other images so that it was
different and unique it would then need
to go and contact and manufacturer and
say Here's the blueprint this is what I
want you to make it might negotiate with
that manufacturer to get the best
possible price and then go and Market it
and sell it those are the capabilities
that are going to arrive you know
approximately in the next five years it
won't be able to do each of those
automatically independently there will
be no autonomy in that system but
certainly those individual tasks
are likely to emerge so that means that
presumably the process of innovation
becomes much much more efficient the
process of managing things but
it's a bit more efficient what does that
mean and let's let's stick with the
upside for the moment I will I promise
you we'll get to all the downsides of
which there are many but but what is
that going to enable us to do I mean
people talk about AI will help us solve
climate change AI will lead to
tremendous you know improvements in
healthcare just talk us through what
some of those things might be so we can
see the upside
intelligence has been the engine of
creation everything that you see around
you here is the product of us
interacting with some environment to
make a more efficient a more a cheaper
table for example or a new iPad
if you look back at history you know
today we're able to create we're able to
produce a kilo of grain with just two
percent of the labor that was required
to produce that same one kilo of grain
100 years ago so the trajectory of
Technologies and scientific invention in
general means that things are getting
cheaper and easier to make and that
means huge productivity gains right the
insights the intelligence that goes into
all of the improvements in agriculture
which give us more with less are the
same tools that we're now inventing with
respect to intelligence so for example
to stay on the theme of Agriculture it
should mean that we're able to produce
new crops that are drought resistant
that are pest resistant that are in
general more resilient we should be able
to to tackle for example climate change
and we've seen many applications of AI
where we're optimizing existing
Industrial Systems we're taking the same
big cooling infrastructure for example
and when we making it much more
efficient again we're doing more with
less so in every area from Healthcare to
education to Transportation we're very
likely over the next two to three
decades to see massive efficiencies
invention think of it as the
interpolation I described with respect
to the images the the the the AI is
guessing the space between the dog the
pink color and the yellow spots it's
imagining something it's never seen
before and that's exactly what we want
from AI we want to discover new
knowledge we want it to invent new types
of science new solutions to problems and
I think that's really what we're likely
to get we I believe that if we can get
that right we're headed towards
an era of radical abundance imagine
every great scientist every entrepreneur
you know every person having the best
possible Aid you know Scientific Advisor
research assistant chief of staff tutor
coach Confidant each of those roles that
are today the you know exclusive
Preserve of the wealthy and the educated
and those of us who live in peaceful
civilized societies those roles those
capabilities that intelligence is going
to be widely available to everybody in
the world just as today no matter
whether you are a you know a millionaire
or you earn a regular salary we all get
exactly the same access to the best
smartphone and the best laptop that's an
incredibly meritocratic story which we
kind of have to internalize you know the
Best Hardware in the world no matter how
rich you are is available to at least
the top 2 billion people
and that is I think that is going to be
the story that we see with respect to
intelligence right enough upbeat stuff
that
that was we've had 20 minutes of our
feet which is
which is uh but you didn't call your
book you know becoming Nirvana you
called it the coming wave and I'm told
that you were thinking it the original
title was going to be containment is not
possible I'm glad you didn't call it
that it wouldn't have sold so well uh
but explain the argument you're making
is not actually Nirvana is around the
corner in fact it's a much much more
subtle argument than that so tell us
what the downsides are and what it is
that your book the focus on containment
is in the book is about
yeah I mean I think I'm pretty wide-eyed
and honest about the potential risks and
you know we if if you take the
trajectory that I predicted that more
powerful models are going to get smaller
cheaper and easier to use which is the
history of the transistor which is the
history of every technology and you know
value basically that we've created in
the world if it's useful then it tends
to get cheaper and therefore it spreads
far and wide and in general so far that
has delivered immense benefits to
everybody in the world and it's
something to be celebrated proliferation
so far has been a really really good
thing but the flip side is that if these
are really powerful tools
they could ultimately Empower a vast
array of Bad actors to destabilize our
world you know everybody has an agenda
has a set of political beliefs religious
beliefs cultural ideas and they're now
going to have an easier time of
advocating for it you know so the
extreme end of this spectrum you know
there are certain aspects of these
models which provide really good
coaching on how to manufacture
biological and chemical weapons it's one
of the capabilities that all of us
developing large language models over
the last year have observed they've been
trained on all of the data on the
internet and much of that information
contains potentially harmful things
that's a relatively easy thing to
control and take out of the model at
least when you're using a model that is
manufactured by one of the big companies
they want to abide by the law they don't
want to cause harm so we basically
exclude them from the training data and
we prevent those capabilities
the challenge that we have
that
everybody wants to get access to these
models and so they're widely available
in open source
you know you can actually download the
code to run albeit smaller versions of
Pi or chat gbt
for no cost and if that trajectory
continues over 10 years you get much
much more powerful models that are much
smaller and more you know transferable
and you know people then who want to use
them to cause harm have an easier time
of it I think that's a really important
distinction that there are you know the
leading companies you Google deepmind
you know open AI who have the biggest
models now and they're a relatively
small number of these ones and they are
bigger and more powerful but not far
behind are a whole bunch of Open Source
ones and so the question is then for
your containment
can you prevent the open source ones
which will potentially be available to
the you know angry teenager in his
garage or her garage can those ones be
controlled or not
okay the darker side of my prediction is
that these are fundamentally ideas
you know their intellectual property
it's knowledge and know-how an algorithm
is something that can largely be
expressed on three sheets of paper and
actually is readily understandable to
most people it's a little bit abstract
but it you can wrap your head around it
the implementation mechanism
you know requires access to vast amounts
of compute today but if in time you
remove that constraint and you can
actually run it on a phone which you
ultimately will be able to do in a
decade then that's where the containment
challenge you know comes into view and I
think that there are also risks of the
centralization centralized question
right this is clearly going to confer
power on those who are building these
models and running them you know my own
company included Google and the other
big Tech providers so we don't eliminate
risk simply by addressing the open
source Community we also have to figure
out what the relationship is between
these super powerful tech companies that
have lots of resources and the nation
state itself which is ultimately
responsible for holding us accountable
so let's go through some of the most
sort of frequently cited risks or indeed
negative consequences and and the one
that you hear a lot is as AIS become you
know equivalent to or exceed human
intelligence across a wide range of
tasks they were be any jobs for any of
us you know why would you employ a human
if you could have an AI so history
suggests that that's bunkum you know
we've never yet run out of jobs and you
know being a good paid up Economist I
think it's a lump of Labor fallacy but
lots and lots and lots of people say
this what's going to happen to the jobs
where are you on that well let's just
describe the lump of Labor fallacy
because I think it's important to sit
with that because that is the historical
Trend so far what it basically means is
when we have
when we automate things and we make
things more efficient we we create more
time for people to invent new things and
we create more health and wealth and
that in itself creates more demand and
then we we end up creating new goods and
services to satisfy that demand and so
we'll continually just keep creating new
jobs and roles and you can see that in
the last couple decades there are many
many roles that couldn't even have been
conceived of 30 years ago from App
designer all the way through to the
present day prompt engineer of a large
language model so that's one trajectory
that is likely
I think the question about what happens
with jobs depends on your time Horizon
so over the over the next two decades I
think it's highly unlikely that we will
see structural disemployment where
people want to contribute their labor to
the market and they just can't compete I
think that's pretty unlikely there's
certainly no evidence of it in the
statistics today
beyond that I do think it's possible
that many people won't be able to even
with an AI produce things that are of
sufficient value that the market wants
them and their AI jointly in the system
I mean AIS are increasingly more
accurate than humans they are more
reliable they can work 24 7. they're you
know more stable and so you know I I
think that that's definitely a risk and
I think that we should lean into that
and be honest with ourselves that that
is actually maybe an interesting and
important destination I mean work isn't
the goal of society sometimes I think
we've just forgotten that actually
society and life and civilization is
about well-being and peace and
prosperity it's about creating more
efficient ways to keep us productive and
healthy many people you know probably in
this room and including us enjoy our
work we love our work and we're lucky
enough and we're privileged enough to
have the opportunity to do exactly the
work that we want I think it's super
important to remember that many many
people don't have that luxury and many
people do jobs that they would never do
if they didn't have to work and so to me
the goal of society is a quest for
radical abundance how can we create more
with radically less and liberate people
from the obligation to work and that
means that we have to figure out the
question of redistribution and obviously
that is an incredibly hard one and
obviously I address it in the book but
is that
to focus on what does taxation look like
in this new regime how do we capture the
value that is created make sure that
it's actually converted into Dollars
rather than just a sort of value add to
GDP okay role of government you need to
have
um
is that
Ai and the rise of AI makes actually the
functioning of democracy ever harder
we're already seeing lots of concerns
about you know deep fakes wrecking the
2024 elections four billion people live
in countries that will have elections
next year people are worrying about 2024
never mind 28 or 34 and we just
um Mustafa and I just had a conversation
with Yuval Harare who is as pessimistic
as you are
um thoughtfully optimistic who basically
said it was the end of democracy
um uh I'm not sure that either you and I
agreed but what is the consequence for
Liberal democracy in the coming decades
in this world of AI I think the first
thing to say is that the state we're in
is is pretty bleak I mean trust in in
governments and in politicians and the
political processes as low as it has
ever been
um you know in in fact 35 percent of
people interviewed in in a Pew study in
the US think that Army rule would be a
good thing so we're already in a very
fragile and anxious State and I think
that the you know to sort of empathize
with you Val for a moment the argument
would be that you know these new
technologies allow us to produce new
forms of synthetic media that are
persuasive and manipulative that are
highly personalized and they exacerbate
underlying fears right so I think that
is a real risk we have to accept that
it's going to be much easier and cheaper
to produce fake fake news right we have
an appetite an insatiable addictive
dopamine hitting appetite for untruth
you know it sells quicker it spreads
faster and that's a foundational
question that we have to address I'm not
sure that it's a new risk that AI
imposes it's something that Ai and other
Technologies accelerate you know in and
that's the challenge of AI that is a
good lens for understanding the impact
that AI has in general it is going to
amplify the very best of us and it's
also going to amplify the very worst of
us
and what about the fact that this is
developing in a world which
geopolitically
split in in a way that it hasn't been at
least in the last couple have been the
post called War World at all so we have
the tensions between the US and China we
have essentially a sort of race for
Global dominance between these two
regimes in that kind of a world how can
you achieve the sort of governance
structures that you write about in your
book that are needed to try and you know
perhaps prevent the most extreme
downsides of AI yeah I mean The
Bachelors I've been accused of being an
optimist about it I've also been accused
of being a utopian about the
interventions that we have to make and I
think that unfortunately that's just a
statement of fact what's required is
good functioning governance and
oversight I mean the the companies are
open and willing to expose themselves to
audit and to oversight and I think that
is a unique moment relative to past
generations of tech CEOs and inventors
and creators across the board we're
being very clear clear that the
precautionary principle is probably
needed and that's a moment when we have
to go a little bit slower be a little
bit more careful and maybe leave some of
the benefits on the tree for a moment
before we pick that fruit in order to
avoid harms I think that's a pretty
novel you know setup as it is but it
requires really good governance it
requires functioning democracies it
requires good oversight I think that we
do actually have that in Europe I think
that the EU AI act which has been in
draft now for three and a half years is
super thorough and very robust and
pretty sensible and so in general I've
been you know a fan of it and kind of
endorsing it but
people often say well if we get it right
in the UK or if we get it right in
Europe and the US what about China I
mean I hear this question over and over
again what about China and I I think
that's a really Danger
first it's sort of
deep China as though China has this sort
of like maniacal suicidal mission to at
all costs at any cost you know sort of
take over the world and you know be the
next dominant Global power I mean so far
I don't see any evidence of of that I
mean you know I'm not ruling it out I'm
not a you know sympathizer but I think
we should just be wide-eyed about the
actions they're actually taking at the
moment they have a self-preservation
Instinct just as we do and the more that
we can appeal to that you know desire to
you know have their citizens benefit
from economic interdependence and from
peace and prosperity and well-being
we're both aligned in those incentives I
think the second thing is it's dangerous
to sort of point a finger at you know
China because
actually we can't just have a race to
the bottom on values we have to decide
what we stand behind right if we're not
you know I mean I I'm a believer that we
shouldn't have a large-scale state
surveillance apparatus enabled by AI we
shouldn't do that just because China are
doing it we shouldn't get into you know
an arms race and take risks just because
they're taking those risks and that's
difficult for some people to accept
because you know they might be hyper
pragmatic and you know I think that that
only leads to an inevitable
self-fulfilling prophecy that we both
end up taking terrible risks which are
unnecessary